all right there are the top nine no not
top ten see that one zero is ten not
nine top ten non-quarterbacks in the nfc
west via pro football focus we're gonna
be pulling names off that board or maybe
we'll go off the board as we
look at the best
non-quarterbacks in the nfc west that's
today's draft the first pick in the
draft hinges on chris's ability to get
this question right here it is the
seahawks had five playoff appearances
when they were teams when they were a
team in the afc the first of their three
wins came
in the 1983 wild card against the
broncos who were the starting
quarterbacks in that game 1983 wild card
seahawks broncos oh man 83 so 83
it is elway i believe i believe he
became the starter during the year there
so elway for the broncos and then hold
on a second here well this has to be um
i'm not sure if i do know this because
it's i don't believe it's dave craig yet
it it's it's it's the lefty coach
jim zorn
[Music]
both counts dave craig
versus steve de berg oh came in in
relief he came in relief that's what it
was outweigh
okay elway was in the middle of the
season came back for the playoff game de
berg returned in the playoff game elway
ultimately spelled him that was always
rookie all right aaron donald aaron
donald begins and ends with aaron donald
one of the great interior defensive
linemen of all time if not the greatest
aaron donald best non-quarterback in the
nfc west yeah thank you well
that was an easy one i can't really
you know disagree there i mean i think
you know we're we're officially putting
aaron donald in a very special class of
people at least i am as i've always said
it's it's already in the greatest
defensive players in the history of the
sport conversation uh so good one there
uh can't really fight that you know
honestly
i'm going i'm staying with i'm stealing
jaylen ramsey you know i don't i don't
give a damn yeah he's next to me i'm
going to go with jaylen ramsey yeah
jaylen ramsey nfl passing league best
corner in the game island guy
not just an island cover guy really
tackles brings a leadership edginess
element to their defense he's not even
on you know top great 10 graded non-qb
see this is why grades you can't always
pay attention to them yeah his grades
i'm sure were a little negative here and
there when you got to cover the greatest
athletes in the world man-to-man all
over the field you're going to have some
negative plays and things like that but
i i think it's hard to to
you know argue that
uh jaylen ramsey isn't one of the best
players in the nfc west
and there are a few others that are not
on that list that we could consider yeah
they make it on but i'm going to go
ahead you're going to leave trent
williams or i'm going to take go ahead
highest paid offensive lineman in league
history signed the contract to stay with
the 49ers they were very happy to keep
him after that trade last year sat out a
whole season a guy who can be a
cornerstone of your offensive line a
little on the old side but that's all
right he's still got a few years left in
him and i would take him right now as uh
let's say and i agree with you ramsay
probably would have been my
thank you so ramsay's off i'll go
william all right good thank you you're
right all right so that's good and this
is i mean i'm i'm i would have been in
the
conversation here with you i would have
gone oh do i want to take trent williams
no do i want to take
you know there's the jamal adams aspect
and then of course there's george kittle
i'm gonna follow you again i'm gonna go
with george kittle i am i mean he's the
highest paid tight end in football for a
reason because he's the best tight end
in football when he's healthy he is he's
a phenomenal blocker he's amazing
you know after the catch he's rare in
the fact that he's a 248 pound tight end
that can literally go 70 yards to the
house if he catches a slam up the middle
or something like that he's a huge part
of that offense but has incredible
versatility in the different ways he can
kind of attack you slot receiver
traditional tight end lined up as a
h-back or a second tight end can do all
that type of stuff uh he's he's too damn
talented so i'll go with kittle
isn't it amazing i know yeah two
defensive players a left tackle a tight
end no running backs
no receivers
i'm thinking jamal adams yeah
right i'm seriously thinking about it
i'm gonna i'll go i'll go deandre
hopkins i gotta i gotta take it a skill
position player i gotta go there yeah i
got two and jamal adams i'm concerned
they're gonna have a problem with him
this year from a contractual standpoint
i i he they they gave up two first round
picks to get him they're gonna have to
pay him and uh they may have to get him
paid by the start of training camp or
maybe he won't be there i know hopkins
will be there for the cardinals so i'll
take hopkins yeah i hear you that's a
good one and you're right it's amazing
that jamal adams things has gone this
far you can see he's not one of the top
10 greatest non-qb's he got off to a
horrible start last year remember
learning that defense he made some
mistakes and again injured
injured
and again
when you're a super talented safety
you get asked to do things that other
safeties don't like covering julian
edelman 70 yards down the field on a
post route yeah most safeties aren't
asked to cover the team's slot receiver
that way so that you got to take that
into account but i like your pick with
hopkins i mean come on he's damn special
he's kind of changing around the
attitude of that football team
man there's a lot to pick up i mean i i
mean i
we got nick bosa who's coming back from
injury buddha baker's out there
uh fred warner
oh i'm gonna go with dk metcalf i'm
gonna go next with that i am i i almost
i almost went fred warner i'm not gonna
lie but i'm gonna go with dk metcalf a
little bit just he's too much of a
difference maker game changer and the
fact that he can dictate coverages and
the way defenses play because he's such
a special entity that way he's a freak
of nature we know that size speed yards
after catch everything like that so yes
i'll go with dk metcalf
is he another one that was off the the
board i don't think he's on there no i
don't think he's on there either my
memory is not
uh cooperating with me today but there
is no dk metcalf there is a jj watt
there is no dk metcalf i'm going to stay
off the board then and i'm going to go
with jamal adams uh because of what he
can be when he's healthy yeah and if the
seahawks get him
compensated to the point where he's
happy and he's motivated and he's driven
they gave up two first-round picks to
get him that tells us all we need to
know what they think of him he should be
on this list yeah i i i don't disagree
with you there he's one of the best
defensive players in football he is and
he is a difference maker and he's the
kind of guy like we've talked about
pretty much with all these guys like if
you're a quarterback or an offensive
coordinator a lot of your game plan is
about where is number 33 where is he
lining up you know when he's in certain
spots and unlocks certain other defenses
and what they do he's a big clue to that
all of those type of things let alone i
mean i don't know he's he's up there as
far as the best in football as far as
just like hey go get the guy with the
ball there's nobody better than jamal
adams he's phenomenal at that
all right
um
man
well i'm
i'm gonna go
with the best
the best pass rusher
in the division even though he's banged
up and leonard floyd as much as i like
him and i've talked about fred warner
and there's eric armstead
man buddha baker's still out there i am
gonna go with nick boza you know got
hurt early in the year last year so i
would expect him to be a hundred percent
when the season comes around and as we
talked about even before he got hurt
last year going into his second year he
was already in the discussion for one of
the best defensive players in the league
not just like best young player best
rookie best defensive player we talked
about it in the super bowl that year
remember with the chiefs 49ers it was
already like no nick bosa's not just
like hey a nice rookie we have on the
team he is one of the best pass rushers
in football he's special that way and i
think he'll be a big boost for that team
i'm gonna go off the board again as well
based on history
chandler jones oh he only had one sack
last year was only in five games but
good lord 19 13 17 11 12 and a half he's
still got gas in the tank i'll take
chandler joe okay that's that's a good
one i like the chandler jones uh pick
certainly all right damn you you went
quick there i wasn't ready for that
um
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with i'm gonna go
with man i'm going 249 or centric here
this is what i don't like about this but
i'm going guys a shock well i know i
don't mean to i'm going to go with fred
warner though i am i think freud warner
i i is arguably the best middle
linebacker in the game i do i think he's
in that type of stratosphere
he is like paramount to the success of
the 49ers defense and when you talk
about like
team speed and the speed of the 49ers
defense a lot of that is predicated a
lot of times when you talk about team
speed on defenses because the
linebackers are fast and it starts right
there with fred warner he is their bobby
wagner of their defense and damn he's
good and pass coverage and the run game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports